it's got to be pretty hard to top a
villain quite so devious and terrifying
as Thanos but that doesn't mean it can't
be done from Death God's to demons to
dictators and beyond here are the Marvel
villains who could give the mad Titan to
run for his money
sure Thanos killed half the universe but
he did it in the pursuit of what he saw
as a higher purpose Pella doesn't need a
reason to kill death is who she is and
what she does
I am hella Odin's firstborn commander
the legions of Asgard the rightful heir
to the throne and the goddess of death
when she kills you you go to her realm
of Hell which is hell with 1l if you're
keeping track and become part of her
undead army which as after life's go
doesn't sound particularly fun this is
why the Vikings try so hard to prove
their value as warriors because only the
bravest and best are chosen by the
Valkyrie to spend eternity feasting in
Odin's Great Hall of el-hawa in theory
everyone else goes to hell the Marvel
version of hella was introduced by Stan
Lee and Jack Kirby and journey into
mystery number 102 her intricate armor
and multi horned helmet are classic
Kirby designs and help make hella one of
his scariest looking characters in fact
of all Thor's enemies she's probably the
scariest after all it's not easy to stop
someone from killing whoever they want
when they have dominion over the realm
of death Kang the Conqueror is a
strategist by nature he never makes a
move until everything is arranged
perfectly and he's confident that
whatever happens is certain to go his
way because he's from the far future
Kang has access to time travel meaning
that when he's orchestrating his
manipulative plans he can change the
past to make the future he wants more
likely any time the Avengers face Kang
they have to realize that he may have
already changed their timeline in ways
they aren't even aware of I hope you
enjoy the rest of your days
this dead hurt what this is where I am
as you might expect conflicts with Kang
can get pretty confusing he first
appeared in 1964 as Avengers number
eight but a previous time-traveling
villain named Rama Tut who'd appeared a
year before in Fantastic Four number 19
was later revealed to be Kang from
another place in this timeline thanks to
the convoluted nature of time travel you
never know when more than one Kang might
show up and at times he may even be at
war with different versions of himself
as happens in the Kang war storyline
that started in Avengers number 128 mess
with Kang and you'll soon wish you'd
never been born
Marvel is lousy with demons but none
greater than Mephisto inspired by
mephistopheles from The Legend of Faust
Mephisto has been Marvel's official
Satan stand-in for over 50 years ever
since his debut in the Silver Surfer
number 3 by Stan Lee and John boo Simha
he's the devil who holds doctor dooms
witch mother captive in his own version
of Hell he's also the one who made the
deal that turned Johnny Blaze into Ghost
Rider like the demon on which he was
based
Mephisto will show up and say plenty of
nice things to you if he thinks you
might sign on his dotted line but if you
don't do exactly what he wants you'll
soon find out that he's more than
capable of ruining your life and your
afterlife the hate monger was a
mysterious villain who first appeared in
Fantastic Four number 21 in 1963 he's an
unnerving masked figure in a piqued hood
that immediately brings to mind the ku
klux klan only he's also got a ray gun
that makes people hate each other he
eventually turns out to be none other
than Adolf Hitler or maybe just one of
his doubles or clones who assumed his
new identity after fleeing Germany this
Hitler dies at the end of that first
hatemonger story but it soon turns out
that hate itself isn't so easy to kill
what makes the hate monger scary isn't
just that he's Adolf Hitler the scary
thing about the hate monger is the idea
of Hitler and they hate he represented
being practically impossible to kill
there are no men like me there are
always men
he just keeps coming back over and over
with new and more powerful technology
every time introduced in issue number 5
of The Ultimates to the first firmament
is the living embodiment of the first
universe that ever existed back at the
dawn of time attacked by the very beings
it it created its consciousness survived
and remained in the void when eternity
the eighth living universe to exist was
weakened by other events out in the
cosmos
the first firmament returned and sought
revenge the sheer scale of the cosmic
power wielded by the first firmament who
has no regard for life in our universe
is deeply terrifying on a cosmic
existential level
fortunately the ultimate sin Galactus
were able to help eternity defeat the
first firmament but it was doubtless a
close call with an unusually powerful
and entirely evil being check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
supervillains are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
you